the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
we'll be fine
and the output
where's my five six
observe that drop them hi our lesson
today concerns functions and a certain
manner of speaking this is perhaps where
a course in calculus should usually
begin after all what we will be studying
is a relationship between certain
variables this is what we mean by a
function in general or at least in
particular with our emphasis on real
variables and graphs that we were
talking about and what we would like to
do now is to motivate the concept of
function from a more general point of
view in terms of the language of sets
that we have talked about and read about
in our supplementary notes let's then
begin with a basic general definition of
what a function is after which we will
specialize and talk about functions of a
real variable for the remainder of the
lecture we begin with a definition
written this way a function f from A to
B see it's written this way but it means
F is a function from A to B means that f
is a rule which assigns to each element
in a set a an element in set B now of
course this may sound like just an empty
bunch of words but if we come here and
look a little bit of a picture we get
the idea as to what's going on namely we
may visualize our sets as circles and
what does the function do the function
assigns to each element of a and element
of B C this element is affectless the
geometric wording again this element is
mapped into this element by F this
element is mapped into this element by F
and this element is mapped into this one
and while we're looking at this perhaps
it would be a good chance to emphasize
not to read more into a definition than
what's already there
you see when we say that F assigns to
each element of a what we mean is we
will not allow something like this to
happen we will not say for example let F
send this element into this one and
this one this becomes non well defined
it becomes ambiguous in other words we
do not want to have to make the value
judgment as to which of two things we
are going to look back at as being what
a Maps into and why that's the case we
mentioned as our course precedes also
notice that when we say that each
element of a is assigned to an element
of B two things are implied here first
of all notice that we do not insist that
all of B be used up you see in other
words his some surplus B's over here
which are not used up by A's with
respect to F and secondly whereas we
prohibit the same a from having two
different images in B we do not prohibit
one B from being the image of two
different elements in a in other words
notice that even though both of these
elements here are assigned to the same
element in B with respect to F there
certainly is no violation of our
definition that each element here was
assigned to an element here by the way
this leads in the literature to three
different terms that we should define
right now one of these is the set a
itself and that's called the domain of F
you see this is what F is defined on the
domain is the set a over here often
abbreviated well there are many
different abbreviations sometimes one
just writes zero in with an F or d ln m
will sub script or a capital d with a
subscript F but we will adapt to these
notations as we need them but for our
purposes all the domain of F is its to
set a it's the set on which F operates
to assign values okay and then the
companion to that is to set B and B
almost again in graphic terms is called
the range of F
and by the way as you look at the range
of F you may get the feeling that
somehow or other this little element
over here is kind of out of place that
maybe somehow rather let me just circle
this let me call this the set C somehow
or other you get the feeling that C
describes much better what F does to a
than B because you see each of the
elements in C is used up as being the
image of at least one element in a
somehow rather you see we could have
deleted this element B without too much
loss of continuity and to get around
this we interject still a third
definition C
it's called the image of f you see image
vs. range image is the part that's
actually used up by F with the mapping
and sometimes this is even abbreviated
as follows you use the same F as one
uses for the function and then a capital
A in parentheses to indicate what this
is a set of all things of the form f of
X where X is in a in other words again
the standard notation if we want to look
at it this way if we call this element
here a and this element here B to
indicate to indicate that a was mapped
into B by the function f for the rule F
we often write that as F of a equals B
now in many places including our text
there is no distinction made between the
image and the range and the reason for
this is that in many situations the
image and the range turn out to be quite
the same thing in fact if they do turn
out to be the same thing we call that a
rather special type of function namely
the function from A to B is set to be on
- if it's image equals its range now
again in terms of words that doesn't say
very much the image equals the range
what does that mean image equals the
range perhaps the best way to see this
is by means of an example the example I
have in mind is this and this happens
many many times in mathematics one
begins with a set in this case I picked
a to be the set consisting of a numbers
1 2 & 3 frequently one defines a
function explicitly on a without any
regard to a second set B for example in
this illustration I've said let F of a
be for a for each a in set capital A
well what are the elements of capital A
they're 1 2 & 3
so according to this recipe what do we
have well F of 1 is 4 F of 2 see it's
what 4 times 2 is 8 and F of 3 that's
what for
times three is 12 let me now invent a
new set B and the elements of B as you
could probably guess are going to be
four eight and twelve and now I look at
my function f from A to B notice that in
this case the function from A to B uses
up all of B in fact in terms of a
diagram you see his a has what one two
and three and his B which is made up of
four eight and twelve now what does F do
it Maps one into four it Maps 2 into 8
and it Maps 3 into 12
you see what does what's happened here a
is not only mapped into B but all of B
is used up in this in other words notice
then that the range of B and the image
of B in this particular case happen to
be the same this will happen in every
single case where we start with a set a
and define a function on a namely we see
what f of X is for each X in a take the
collection of all those images call that
set B and then you see by default so to
speak B will be both the range and the
image of F and it's in this sense that
in most textbook examples that we deal
with we need not make any distinction
between the range of the function
and the image of the function but
roughly speaking then just to keep
things straight a function is called on
to if the entire range is used up in the
mapping but if there are elements of the
range which are not used up as images
then the function is simply called into
or not onto but at any rate this is the
concept of what we mean by Anto now a
second feature that one talks about with
functions which in no way is connected
with on to this but which is a very
important independent feature is
something which is called a one-to-one
function let's look at that for a moment
too
say for example let's suppose I have a
function f defined on my set a the
question is f maps a1 into a particular
element of B and it Maps a2 into a
particular element of B now there are
two possibilities that can happen it one
is that F of a 1 and F of a 2 will be
different elements of B in other words
what will happen is is that two distinct
elements of a will have distinct images
in B on the other hand it's possible
it's possible that the two different
elements of a have the same element or
the same image in B now by and large
where as nothing is wrong when this
happens it does cut down our operating
speed to some extent when it does
because you see frequently to study a
particular function we may want to look
at the image rather than the domain and
some however you see if two different
elements can map into the same element
in the image then you see when we look
at the image we have no way of knowing
which of these two elements we're
talking about so in other words then if
it should turn out that no two different
elements in a can have the same image
and B in other words that notice what
this thing here says you see if what
this is the image of a1 this is the
image of a two it says what if a1 and a2
have the same image then they must be
the same element now if that happens and
again as I show you over here it doesn't
have to happen if that happens the
function is called one-to-one for
example here is a picture I've drawn in
which a function is one-to-one okay
by the way I've drawn this picture so
that my function f is both one-to-one
meaning what that no two elements in a
have the same
imogen be and secondly but it also
happened to be on to here namely no
element of B was left out by F now that
wasn't crucial for example if I do this
notice now that the function from A to B
is still one-to-one no two different
elements in a have the same image and B
but now you see the function is no
longer on two because they happen to be
elements in B which are not mapped into
under F by elements of a now what is
nice of course is that if a function
happens to be both one-to-one and onto
notice that we can induce a new function
which I'll call G from B to a by
essentially reversing the arrowheads
here you see if the function is both
one-to-one and onto by reversing the
arrowheads instead of getting a function
from A to B I do get a function from B
to a this function is called the inverse
function and will play a very important
role in much of our course which follows
the important point to notice however is
that if the function is not both
one-to-one and onto you cannot reverse
the arrowheads believe it or not we say
I can reverse them can't I why can't I
reverse them over here and the answer is
well look if we include these being in
here suppose we reverse the arrowheads
now look at B what is the domain of G
well for B to be the domain every
element of B has to be assigned to
something in a by G but look at these
two elements over here G doesn't act on
those at all in other words if the
original function is not on 2 then when
you reverse the arrowheads you haven't
defined the new function on your whole
domain here in another sense if the
function was not one-to-one when you
start it in other words suppose this
happened so f was not one-to-one now you
see when you try to reverse your
arrowheads
notice that the element here in B is
assigned to two different elements in a
and we agreed that we wouldn't allow
that to happen
okay so far so good notice that that
particular part of our course has
nothing to do with real variables and
the like meaning when we're talking
about sets they can be sets of arbitrary
numbers now what I'd like to do is zero
in on our specific calculus of a single
variable course and let's go back to our
old friend who somehow or other has made
an appearance in every lecture that
we've had so far let's go back to s
equals 16 T squared only now we're not
going to repeat the same old stuff that
we did before with it we're now going to
get slightly more sophisticated namely
when we talk about s equals 16 T squared
what problem was being done here you're
assuming that there is no air resistance
an object is being held above the ground
you release the object and the distance
s that the object falls in feet after T
seconds is given by s equals 16 T
squared now if we think about that for a
while we realize that that does not tell
the whole picture obviously the S equals
16 T squared applies only to the time in
which that object is falling perhaps
what we should have said was this that
until you release the object it doesn't
fall any distance at all then from the
instance you release it it starts to
fall a distance s given by 16 T squared
not forever but until it hits the ground
let's call T sub G the time at which
this thing hits the ground you see this
recipe that we called s equals 16 T
squared is not in effect forever it's an
effect only when T is between 0 and T
sub G and by the way hopefully once the
object hits the ground it won't fall any
further in other words for any time
after T sub G the distance that it's
fallen is 16 T sub G squared meaning
this is the distance that has fallen
when it hits the ground and it stays
there if we wanted to graph this you see
and notice how we are refining our
previous result the graph is not this
you see the graph is
the distance is zero until T equals zero
then the distance that Falls increases
up till the time the object hits the
ground and then it levels off like this
and by the way in the terms of making in
terms of making a fewer sides notice
that this curve here does represent a
one-to-one function namely if you pick
two different times in this strip you
have two different distances two
different times cannot yield the same
distance as opposed to the fact let's
call this t1 and t2 as opposed to the
fact that once the thing hits the ground
our function is no longer one-to-one in
fact for any two values of T once the
thing is hit the ground we have the same
s value in other words what we're saying
is what that once the object hits the
ground it really makes no difference
what T is s is still going to be 16 T
sub G squared now that was just an aside
the reason I mentioned this is to
motivate a very important type of domain
that takes place when we deal with
functions of real numbers in most cases
when we do a physical experiment it's
over some time interval we put something
into effect and say let's measure it for
one hour or let's measure it from now
until three o'clock tomorrow in other
words in general whereas a domain of a
function can be anything we want it to
be in most real-life laboratory
situations our domain happens to be a
connected interval whatever that means
intuitively in fact let's try to talk
about that in more detail in other words
a very special type of domain that one
uses when one talks about functions of a
real variable they are called intervals
written as sets if a is less than B we
talk about what the set of all X which
are less than a and a greater than a and
less than B by the way that's called the
open interval from A to B it's written
this way with parentheses the set of all
elements from less than a less than B
and greater than a inclusively
is called the closed set or the closed
interval from A to B and it's written
this way and pictorially you can't tell
these apart namely if this is a and this
is B both of these pictorially or what
and interval as we think of it
intuitively namely it's this stretch but
in one case the endpoints a and B are
included and in the other case the
endpoints are exclude they're included
in the closed interval they're excluded
in the open interval and again notice
that since a point has no thickness we
have no way of telling just by looking
at the figure which of these two is
meant unless we draw in the appropriate
diagram this way by the way notice also
that an interval can be half open and
half closed I mean for example one could
talk about how about including the left
endpoint but excluding the right
endpoint see why couldn't we talk about
something like this in which case we
would have written the half open half
closed and devote this particular way
now again this is all notation it's
things that you can memorize things that
are emphasized in the text but the thing
that I wanted to try to have you see
from the lecture is why we concentrate
so heavily on the things called
intervals it's because in most
situations when we deal with functions
of a real variable our so-called input
is usually defined on some continuous
interval all times from such-and-such to
such-and-such
now by the way again notice that the
picture just as we've been talking about
before the picture comes in handy namely
1/2 being in the open interval from 0 to
1 does not need a picture to interpret
it namely since 1/2 is greater than 0
but less than 1 by definition 1/2 is in
this interval on the other hand by use
of a picture I think it becomes rather
easy to visualize what it is that were
saying when 1/2 is in this particular
interval again notice when somebody says
does 0 belong to this interval notice
that subtlety about open and closed
point versus dot namely 0 does not
belong
- the open interval from zero to one but
it does belong for example to the closed
interval from zero to one because what
is the basic difference between these
two in this one the endpoints are not
included in this one the endpoints are
included now a companion to interval is
a very important building block of this
course it's something called a
neighborhood now in terms of a
definition a neighborhood isn't a very
exciting thing and a neighborhood of a
point see a neighborhood of X equals C
is simply an interval which contains C
inside you want C to be inside the
interval now what does that mean
intuitively well what it means is pick
any interval which has C inside maybe we
can go from this point to this point
this would be called a neighborhood a
neighborhood of C by the way you may
notice I've drawn this as an open
interval the idea is that we really want
C to be inside the interval we do not
want the situation where C is one of the
endpoints and whereas we'll talk about
this in more detail later the important
point is that in many of our
investigations in calculus we will want
to study what's happening just before we
get to a certain point and just after we
leave that point and somehow or other if
we let that point be at the very end of
our interval we have no information for
example if that point is the left
endpoint we don't know what's happening
before we get to the point if it's the
right endpoint we don't know what's
happening afterwards and that's why
you'll find in the textbook that a
neighborhood is defined to be an open
interval which contains C in other words
we want to make sure that C is in the
interior here by the way in many cases
it turns out algebraically to be easier
if this happens to be what we call a
symmetric neighborhood in other words if
C is in the middle C now we won't go
into that right now but if C happens to
be in the middle that's called a
symmetric neighborhood in fact another
way of writing that is to say
one pick some definite distance H and
what do you write down you write down C
- H - C + H and that puts C right in the
middle of this particular interval and
you see the idea is that when you're
looking at what's happening to a
function you may lose symmetry for
example in this particular graph that
I've drawn notice that at this
particular point I've marked off equal
intervals on both sides of L but notice
that when I come down here they do not
project on to equal intervals on either
side of C in other words they would have
been if this had been a straight line
frequently what we do in a case like
this is we say well look at if we're
interested in seeing what happens near C
why don't we just not see this is non
symmetric why don't we just take the
smaller of these two widths and see what
happens in the symmetric part in other
words if the neighborhood is not
symmetric we can always make it
symmetric and so there really isn't that
much to worry about in that particular
respect but why are we interested in
neighborhoods in the first place and the
answer is that in many cases what we're
going to be doing is studying what's
happening near a particular point C and
want to know what's happening just
before and what's happening just after
the next important concept that's
connected with neighborhoods is the idea
of a deleted neighborhood and that in
turn is very strongly connected with
zero over zero for example consider the
function f of X which is x squared minus
9 over X minus 3 if we let X equal 3 if
the input is 3 notice that the output
becomes 9 minus 9 over 3 minus 3 or 0
over 0 on the other hand on the other
hand if X is any number whatsoever
except x equals 3 no harm is done with
this as an input consequently what one
is talking about now is the only time
you get that 0 over 0 form is when X is
straight what happens if you're in the
neighborhood of 3 but not equal to 3
itself you see what I'm driving at here
is pick any number X in this interval
other than 3 itself and notice that f of
X can be
in this way as long as X is not equal to
three we can cancel X minus 3 from
numerator and denominator remember we
can't divide by zero and now we see what
that as long as X is not equal to three
f of X is perfectly well defined and
consequently this is what motivates the
concept of a deleted neighborhood namely
everything is fine in this whole
neighborhood except for three itself so
to avoid that unpleasant tree let's just
delete that point and that's called a
deleted neighborhood and you see what we
do when the neighborhood is deleted we
still going to talk about what how close
you are to that point and by the way
this brings us to another very
fascinating aspect of what's going on
between our geometry and our arithmetic
do you really talk about the distance
between numbers I mean is seven near
three a guy says well what you mean is
seven near three well I would say here
that seven is very near to three you see
I mean do you mean when you say that
seven is near three you certainly don't
mean close to in the geometric sense
you mean the difference between them is
small in other words the next thing that
we have to talk about is how when we
talk about being close to a point which
is a geometric term how do we talk about
that algebraically you see geometrically
how do you talk about the distance
between x1 and x2 well if you're going
this way
it's just what x2 minus x1 if you're
going the other way the directed
distance this way is x1 minus x2 in any
event the distance between these two
points is just the magnitude of the
difference of these two numbers and that
leads you see to the concept that's hit
quite heavily in our text and that is
the concept of absolute value perhaps
one of the most critical analytical
geometric topics that we tackle in our
early part of our course analytically we
define the absolute value written with
vertical bars here x1 minus x2 the
absolute value of x1 minus x2 to be the
positive square root of x1 minus x2
squared and in plain English all this
says is what see when you square and
then take the positive square root
you haven't undone what you've done
before all you've done is what if it's
positive here
you haven't changed anything but if x1
minus x2 are negative when you square it
and extract the positive square root all
you've done is change the sign just like
you're supposed to let me give you an
example suppose you're faced with the
absolute value of X minus 3 is less than
2 what does this say geometrically
geometrically what it says is that X is
within two units of 3 in terms of a
picture all you have to do now is draw
in 3 map off 2 units on either side and
for X to be within 2 units of 3 all you
know is is that X has to be in here in
other words look at how easily you can
solve this particular problem on the
other hand you can always go back to the
basic definition and say wait a second
this means the positive square root of x
minus 3 squared is less than 2 so I will
square both sides if you do that you get
X minus 3 squared is less than 4 if you
now collect terms and expand you get x
squared minus 6x plus 9 minus 4 that's
what plus 5 is less than 0 this factors
into X minus 1 times X minus 5 is less
than 0 the only way the product of two
numbers can be negative is if the
factors have different signs since this
is X minus 5 is less than X minus 1 this
must be the smaller of the 2 this must
be the larger of the 2 to say that X
minus 1 is greater than 0 is the same as
saying that X is greater than 1 to say X
minus 5 is less than 0 is the same as
saying that X is less than 5 you put
that all together and notice that even
though it wasn't quite as comfortable we
can obtain the same answer algebraically
as we can obtain geometrically in other
words our relationship between algebra
and geometry remains the same again when
you can draw the picture it's worth a
thousand words if you can't draw the
picture or you
suspicious about the picture especially
when it involves point versus dot then
what you do is resort to the analytic
definition these do not replace one
another they work hand in hand finally
what we must talk about now is the
arithmetical functions can we combine
functions to form functions and the
answer is yes
first of all in talking about the
arithmetic functions what must we do we
must first at least define what it means
for two functions to be equal well for
two functions to be equal all we insist
on is that first of all they're defined
on the same domain and secondly that for
each input in the domain each function
gives you the same output for example
suppose a is a set whose elements
consist of 0 and 1 and suppose B is also
the set whose elements consist of 0 and
1 1 such function would be F at maps 0
into 0 it maps 1 into 1 another function
which I'll call G
çf does what it maps 0 into 0 & 1 into 1
what does G do G Maps 0 into 1 & 1 into
0 notice that F and G are different they
both have the same domain they both have
the same image but notice that elements
the element they're not the same namely
F and G do different things to 0 F sends
0 into 0 G send 0 into 1 so I can tell F
and G apart and because I can tell them
apart they're not equal alright so
equality means I can't tell F from G now
the next kind of question is how do you
read how do you do arithmetic with F and
G can I add two functions can I multiply
two functions can I subtract two
functions and the answer again turns out
to be yes and not only yes but yes in a
rather simple way let's again do this by
means of examples suppose we define f of
X to be 2 X for all X in a namely if a
is 1 to 3 F of 1 would be 2 F of 2 will
be 4 F of 3 will be 6 let's define
another function on a let's call it G G
of X will be X plus 1 for each X in a in
other words G of 1 will be 2 G of 2 will
be 3 G of 3 will be 4 now the point is
can I add f of X and G of X well sure f
of X is 2x G of X is X plus 1 so if I
add these I get H of X is 3 X plus 1 in
a similar way I have multiplied these
two well sure again f of X is 2x G of X
is X plus 1 if I multiply these together
I get what 2x times X plus 1 which is
the same as 2x squared plus 2x now of
course this probably doesn't look too
smooth because there's no pictures here
all we're saying is this his a and all
you're saying is that if you add F and G
what do you get if a is 1 3 X plus 1 is
4
two times three plus one is seven three
times three plus one is ten in other
words in this case our image if I want
to call it B would look like this
this would be the sum of the two
functions F and G and similarly for the
product I could do the same kind of a
thing in other words I can just
arithmetic aliy since both the output of
F and the G machines are real numbers
and the sum of two real numbers is a
real number I can add and multiply
functions to form functions but there's
one other important way of combining
functions in calculus a way which is
very very important and one which we may
not have seen too much of before and so
let me close our lecture for today with
an emphasis on that particular topic
it's called composition of functions and
to see what composition of functions
means think of a particular example
where maybe the F machine f of X is 2x
now let's think of it this way we run X
through the F machine the output will be
2x now we run the output of the F
machine into the G machine now what does
the G machine do if X is the input X
plus 1 means 1 more than the input the G
machine always adds on 1 to the input to
give you the output well if the input is
2x the output will be 2x plus 1 notice
that these two together can be thought
of as being one function machine which
I'll call the Q machine in other words
what happens for the Q machine is what X
runs into the F machine the output of
the F machine becomes the input of the G
machine and the output of the G machine
is then the output of the Q machine the
Q machine is sort of built with
component parts here and the reason that
this is very very important is that this
comes up in calculus all the time where
the first variable is related to the
second variable the second variable has
a definite relationship to the third
variable and we now want to relate the
first variable to the third variable and
the way we write that and I guess this
is hard to see this is not an all over
here it's a little circle like a dot and
it's
all the composition of G and F it's not
goth it's G circle F and the q machine
is what you write it this way and maybe
if you look at the picture you can see
exactly what's happening here that the
you apply F to X and then apply G to the
result in other words just looking at
this picture it becomes rather apparent
that Q of X is just 2x plus 1 notice you
see that the domain of the Q machine is
the same as the domain of F the input of
the Q machine is what goes into the F
machine the output the image of the Q
machine is the image of the G machine in
other words just this particular thing
now this type of function combination
called composition is a very intricate
thing it depends on the order in which
you do these things now this is a rather
interesting point for example when you
add two numbers a and B it makes no
difference in which order you add them
on the other hand when you divide two
numbers a and B the quotient does depend
on the order in which you divided them
well the same thing is true here
let's call P the function which starts
with the G machine followed by the F
machine and as this lecture wears on I
think maybe there's a reason for making
this circle look like I know maybe this
is starting to look a little bit like
fog at this time it's not I want you to
see is that what we do now is we start
see what are we going to do here now
we're going to start with the G machine
first then the F machine in other words
what happens now if the input is X the
output of the G machine is one more than
the input that would make the input X
plus 1 to the F machine what does F do
remember F doubles F doubles the input
so the output here would be what twice X
plus 1 in other words what would P of X
look like if X goes into the P machine
what comes out is twice X plus 1 or 2 X
plus 2 on the other hand when we put the
F in the G machine in the other order
and for
q of X what was the output say let's go
back here and look the output was 2 X
plus 1 in other words do you build a
different function machine by
interchanging the F and the G and the
answer is yes in other words what I'd
like you to see for concluding this part
is that whereas everything was pretty
straightforward up until now the most
important new concept one which was not
so intuitive is the one that's called
the composition of functions it's the
one that occurs all the time in related
rates problems it will be using it over
and over again in this course ok
and all I want you to see is that first
of all when you use the composition of
functions what you get depends on the
order in which you combine them and that
secondly and most importantly that
neither of these is the same as this
that combining two functions is not the
same as multiplying the outputs of two
different functions well I think that's
sort of enough of a mouthful for one
sitting our main aim today was to
introduce functions the language that
we're going to be using the rest of the
way because after all if we don't if we
don't have the vocabulary established it
will not be second nature to talk about
the concepts starting next time and
beyond we will deal more with specific
calculus contexts but until next time
goodbye funding for the publication of
this video was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate